boy i'm thinking about you last time you
were here um
you know you're a fan of our show and
richard came in and started crying
one of the characters on the king of the
hill that died uh oh
cotton hill died yeah oh he had i
remember him crying
didn't he i remember listening to your
show and he was crying because king of
the hill was over like when hank talks
about bobby and like how proud how proud
of him he is and stuff it's like
you know it's
it makes me sad it's so sweet you know
what about the one where hank's father
died
that too yeah cotton was awesome man i
see i'm such a [ __ ] weirdo i'm crying
right now of a cartoon but
i really get sad over it like
cotton was the best character
he was just like such a great character
and god he loves you i mean he said i'm
a big fan of richard christie uh but
what what was the character you cried
over richard i've well i've cried a lot
i can probably cry now thinking about it
thinking about tell me
maybe you'll cry there was an episode
uh that like i tear up even thinking
about it where
uh oh my god oh oh the 4h
the
the meat judging because i used to do
meat judging and anytime hank is proud
of bobby it makes me cry
you [ __ ] maniac
mike is laughing at you i don't want to
laugh
you can laugh because you're cartoon
characters
yeah but they're based on real life like
it's like you're i'm watching my life
it reminds me of growing up and hank
hill reminds me of my dad i love it all
right all right
sorry wow
the tears are going already just
thinking about the the hill family is
yeah yeah and
they're richard i know but you know
there's a lot i've i watched the cinco
de mayo episode yesterday for cinco de
mayo so there's a lot of great episodes
that mike has left us with so do you
think you know more about uh king of the
hill than mike does
i know a lot i don't know if i know as
much as mike but uh yeah i mean i might
know more because i'm trying to remember
the cinco de mayo
it's called
king of the ant hill
right right all right who answers
quicker okay
ready here's a question richard what
beer does hank and his alamo
oh there's not a buzzer i can okay
how many men does cotton hill claim to
have killed 50.
[Laughter]
fiddy i win
all let's do one at a time though okay
here you go all right richard you first
uh what is the name of hank's boss at
the propane store buck strickland all
right
mike how many episodes of king of the
hill are there oh geez okay
270
five now wrong what is it richard do you
know how many episodes of king of the
hill are there i was going to say 218.
259 according to wikipedia oh what oh
that's right okay all right here we go
um
all right i like better when you guys
chime in fast okay whoever gets this
free when did king of the hill debut on
tv 1997. god he is
he's faster than you mike
sorry my body hills middle school is
named after which texas legend tom
landry tom landry i finally got one
rusty shackleford is the alias for
watching gribble
he got you on that one oh damn what
real-life musician is a spokesperson for
the manchester united chuck manchin
[Laughter]